うーさーさーさーああいやだーーーー
はず雪なのはなぁのですねはい動画で受けてると思うんですけども花粉症でも本当に
限界に近くて良いを生活することが不可能になってきましたじゃあ薬飲めばいいじゃ
んっていうことで何か市販の薬とか鼻水とベッドがめっちゃ飲んでるんですけども
今井つきませんジャージャー病院行きだって話なんですけどもうか星を治したいから
耳鼻科の方に連絡したらあのディズニー
イーランド並みに待つ時間がありますと言われていえねーってことでもうどうしようも
することができませんじゃに僕の症状は目と鼻と口で鼻がつまりこの鼻水がなく家に来
てもらってなって目もなんかさカサカサ回大会行った時も
ああっ枚だ
ということでどうすればいいのかわかんないとちょっとネットで調べてみました
なんで結局でなんか生活とかも大事なんですけども食べモードがすごい大事らしいん
ですよ腸内環境がよくなるだけで結構花粉症の症状が緩和されるって聞いたことがある
んで最近メディアにヨーグルトかくって言いますよくなったかはわかりませんがねいう
わけで閣議は良い食べ物をネットで調べてみましたまず腸内環境を整え
ことが大事らしいですヨグルトいいですよたぶんあとはお店はお味噌も何か良いらしい
です発酵食品は善玉菌である乳酸菌やビフィズス菌が入ってるねハッコウセイ ia
みたいなとこあるらしいですよそして後シメ様
カフー症の原因はしスタメンというアレルギー物質らしいです dh どこが癖際遺産
a子サテン隊員さんはそのヒスタミンというアレルギー物質の
働きを抑える力あるらしいですめっちゃいいよ発酵食品の中まで決め粒効くらしいです
そして後ボマーグラミーらしいでこれも花粉アレルギー症とを抑える何か入ってる
らしいですよ立学校半ばでナット後誤報時なんかもいいらしいです何でかと言いますと
速報と全員が咲く入ってるんで全裸モンキー豊富やって作用があるしてです後ぬか漬け
も発酵食品ですそして最後著
これーたーぼーはずにちょっといいらしいでこれも実は発行増備になったかかを発酵さ
せて作られてるらしいねはいというわけでですね今中で僕が過ぎ好んで食べるといっ
たらもうヨーグルトかキムチとチョコレートぐらいなんですよねこんな後まずが来てて
も時間がもったいねえということ
これ人集めに合体させたら最強に花粉に強い料理ができるんじゃないかと思いまして
今回はこれらを合わせて花粉に最も木くずバラせ料理を作ってみようと思います経済
でしょ
底辺ふわーっというわけで所すぐっはいみなさんというわけで創先生だよ早速作って
いきましょうねまず先に行ってき
お粗末連絡様水ですというわけで精霊作ってみることにしましょうこちらのフラスコ
くらいのサイズ感で作っていきましょう
もう一度言っておきます間違いなく笠間といいですねはお料理会人生まず現状入れ礼装
の食材からどんどん入れていきましょうまず後まあバルをとりあえず入れていき
ましょう
[音楽]
が続いてキムチ入れていきます
パワーならすぎ鼻がすう進んだよねきゅんじゃあ個人的に結構有効な気がするんですよ
[音楽]
入りましたそれで大きな声でていきましょうああ
自分もしましたもう取りためのつかないことになってきたかこれで続いてチョコレート
を入れましょうところと細かくグループになっていきもなく
ではチョコを入れていきます
[音楽]
蒼前様ですやっぱ地味にねヨーグルトそうだが一番体に気がすんだよねー
これでエアーではに入れさせていただきます
うわぁ凄いことになってきましたさあどんどん減ってまいりました続いての食材は
ヌカヌカヌカですわからないも分かったんですけどた発行してればいいと思います
に入りました大しよう
ん
家がは3 the 誰もさ軍でもあたらのマンなくてねもう三郷仕様の違いもわからん
方が詰まっていて味が分かりません入れません
様子が届いては南東ですもう何でも入れて言います納豆ってもなんか体にいいっていう
イメージしかないんですよね
予習水なるでしょうか入れます
[音楽]
ええええっ
運命では続けて鯖んです鯖に出てきますもうねサーが今中に入れるじゃないと思うんだ
けど僕の目標は味とかじゃなくカクーンを治す
食べ物を作ることなんでまあそうだし入れましょう
[音楽]
もうやばいもうやばいも山下た後に5号です大事な根菜類ですよでも入ってるものなに
聞くと本当に体に良さそうな気がするんですよね
いい感じに刻んでおきましたたぶんこれで大丈夫だと思います
相手下すべての食材が混ざり合う張りましたこちらですともうやばいもう
やばいやばいますベージュが皆さん大事なのは味ではございません効果です果たして
これが花粉症に効くのかどうか
さっそく試してみたいと思いますわぁ黒いけどまずはズルしかないですまでましょう
あっふわぁまあじゃあやばい
あーはいというできましたこれがおそらく最も家具に効くだろうし造替きょうの料理で
ございますアズは知りませんってかもうまずいの確定してますよろしくお願いします
もーくせいでてお薬うううを送りと思って僕開発したんで
なんかとん汁の匂いがします何処からともが出てきたんださあというわけで
早速飲んでみようと思います味は不味いはもう知ってるでは高価です効果大事なのは
飲んでみようと思いますいただきます
[音楽]
てきましたます
th
ふーん a
乾杯
[音楽]
はぁ
そういうゆっくり来たっけこなかった今ておっ俺
わっ俺はぁあっは
おっ
[音楽]
くん
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
旅ました
ええええええええええええ
[音楽]
やばいやばいはビッグびっくりまあまあ杏から言いましょうあの予想通りクソまずかっ
たです何かそのなんか魚とか魚とかなっとそのぬ縁家がもう割れってなってて生臭さあ
に何か見その変なしょっぱさも混ざりつつローターヨーグルトのまろやか磨きたと思っ
たらチョコレートの阿南が襲いかかってき者答えて結構ヌルヌルしてるなぁと思ったら
ごぼうの出資
期間が襲い掛かってほんとんとしていましたね御馳走様でしたら肝心な高価なんです
けども
花粉なはぁっはぁっはぁっ
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ